comment type énergique et en qui on a
fait du lebron et puisqu'on vous
rappelle qu'on est là pour lui c'est un
sujet de gérard oury
c'est une histoire qui se passa entre
louis de funès et moi on a tourné une
bonne partie la moitié du film en italie
à naples à rome un lac de bours sauna à
pise portofino
le bon départ et je roulais à bbc qu'un
film en couleur cinémascope généralement
chez des films comiques avec très peu de
moyens cette fois ci c'est un film riche
c'est la première fois que je tourne
dans un film avec autant
l'occasion je connaissais louis de funès
on a tourné ensemble dans la traversée
de paris avec jean gabin
on a un peu les mêmes goûts on aime
jardiner et on parle autant jardinage de
spectacle entre les prises je
connaissais oury intacte auprès de la
police
vas-y recommencer mais puisqu'on vous
répète qu'on ait de la palud se met dans
la peau d'un personnage alors quand on
laisse les abîmes ce chapeau par exemple
vous imaginez bien que je n'aime pas sa
peau comme ça ou rentrer chez moi
les gosses rire est d'avoir un père qu'à
une bille de clown
alors voilà au début du film je suis
français moyen je suis dans les guette
je voulais y est je suis représentant
chaque année à carcassonne en vacances
parce que j'ai des amis à quelques
semaines et cette année là je me suis
dit comme j'ai ma petite de chevaux pour
la première fois de ma vie j'ai le
moteur gdi cette année
je vais aller en italie alors inspecteur
de dégâts et on va partir on va quitter
mon appartement
mais j'ai à peine fait 300 m qui a en
gros une voiture qui n'en finit pas
qu'ils me rentrer dedans et ma pauvre de
chevaux situera les écraser et ce
monsieur c'est l'individu que vous avez
côté voilà qui est grasse comme mais
comme une punaise
et alors à 9 h on parle je me suis je
réfléchis jamais avoir donné une voiture
que ce n'était pas nouvelle c'était ma
première vue c'est une voiture très
ancienne qui démarrait à la manivelle à
la manivelle pandore et marché très
lentement maintenant je marchais comme
ça qui devient un cycliste qui nous
dépasse il m'avait passé tellement vite
que j'ai cru que j'étais arrêté
alors moi je suis descendu à a formé
tant aux pme voiture m'a écrasé j'ai
reçu une carte de la prévention routière
comme je suis conducteur d'élite mais
ils ont quand même pas agacé vous avez
quand même pas bien c'est dur est devant
moi j'ai jamais eu d'accident non parce
que je suis faible
si j'étais fort voudrais je voudrais
avoir ma méchanceté la timbale
de même je ne peux pas je nourris à tu
raisonnes histoires vécues mais un ami
musicien verra voilà la plaisance et
qu'ils feraient si vous mettre carrément
parce que c'est une histoire qu'elle
fasse enfin je voulais encore de vous en
face le satisfaire des galères enfin il
partait d'une conjoncture américains
passionnés tous les tambours et
trompettes ont fait un gala à la glose
présenterez une plaisanterie des deux
salles deux gardiens quand ils voyaient
de choses petites voitures qui n'allait
pas trop vite et que tu es comment
dirais-je occupé par une famille du père
la mère des trois enfants avec leurs
trois voter avec leur moteur dans lequel
il passait delà il ralentissait mais je
ralentissais presque pas à leur lot d'un
chat deux choses alors d'ozoir ou alors
allez c'est pas passé puis ça dure et ça
devrait avoir l'eau de pluie un des
musiciens se mettaient à la lunette
arrière
il a une vraie souffrance tellement il
connaît la vie matérielle bon père de
famille ses enfants
[Rires]
les autres professionnels
voilà une deux entre autres la pêche
toile scénario de l'aller c'était aller
le packtec alors un peu mal tu me tues
tu dis tu t'amènes avec ta grosse
bayonne sarholz la rolls royce et le
rôle qu il est remonté même 10 à ces
gens n'oublient fou et alors je ne peux
pas partir en vacances et ses vacances
ont fait je suis rendu chez lui et moi
une idée me vient je lui téléphone mon
nom chef des dons
j'ai dit et je lui offre des vacances
avec je lui dis j'ai des amis qui sont
un temps l'italie et ils ont été
rappelés en amérique d'urgence la
papamobile même et dans le sud d'une
arrière compris non mélangés aux
sociétés et alors cette voiture là il
faut que moi je dois aller là prendre un
appel à ramener à bordeaux puis j'ai la
rage au niveau des vous le faire elle
dit c'est formidable je dis c'est une
cadillac équipe fabuleuse saga culture
ne lis que téléphone et de ce que les
lits et et entre temps tout de suite
après nous apprenons également que cette
voiture est bourré de drogue
elle est bourrée de les pare chocs sont
en or il ya un gros énorme diamant il ya
des les bourrées de deux choses il faut
pour passer la douane encore mieux pour
balader sa c2 c'est l'homme en d'éviter
les halles à l'histoire ce n'est pas la
voiture qui est suspect c'est l'homme
alors définitive le propos de funès
c'est de trouver un base core duo que
personne ne soupçonne qui a un casier
judiciaire absolument vierge et de lui
faire passer la frontière avec sa bonne
mine son casier visio virgin est
absolument soupçonné de rien avec cette
voiture qui vaut 25 ans de prison et 25
milliards et le funes va suivre lui
derrière son trésor en s'assurant qu'il
lui arrivera rien et enfin qu'il va
arriver 25 mille choses et américains
il ya des péripéties mais ça veut dire
la fin la fopao 10 lancers quand même
quelques péripéties raconte maison
adhémar ici à la fin je suivais 7 que
liège
d'abord c'est pas à couvrir mais
confondant marche arrière avec la nation
ça s'est déjà fait ça j'ai fait comme
cayman fort la fin comme il était debout
jeudi à nantes team ce qui veut bien
annoncer et je m'en vais derrière c'est
vrai que j'ai manqué de tomber à l'eau
dans le port de jeu mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
cette bagarre
en fait alors c'est beaucoup moins
filandreuses que ça dure deux heures sa
plus basse visite a duré deux accords
dont ça se passe tout à fait c'est très
rapide serait plus rapide mais c'est
l'auteur souris ils avaient tous un
passé vous avez le débat s'il avoue
rester là poussée par la cour comme un
con là regardez moi ça été gâchée valait
rien compris le film quand même non pas
du tout ce sont des exécutants il est
dit ce sont les exécutants sont ils font
ce qu'on leur dit il ne pense absolument
pas envie d'apprendre il faut que ce
dernier faisait du gars qui comprend
rien lui les vins il fait lui des
diaboliques vous voyez ça va si j'avais
laissé neige j'aurais eu l'air trop
intelligent génère du gars qui sait rien
alors je compose pas dit ma main sur
tatou qui font motards je parle là les
échos mentionnent tout ça je m'aperçois
lui le corniaud il était joué par de
funès pas si bel et bien du temps vous à
la personne est alors je veux manger à
leur faim
fort de tout ce que je sais je lui fait
du chantage
cette interminable il est là il est
comme il semble pas l'espagne
il déchante de rila jamais santé de
genève
alors là je pensais bien si je suis
content il apparaît alors à quoi s'est
il fait 2 1 n'oubliez pas à l'emmener
avec vous un petit casse croûte
parce que si vous avez un temps on a
présenté un encas
[Musique]